come on come on little closer yes hey
how's it going my name is Pierre welcome
to Lucas to today unite are gonna murder
some people and it's coming sorry I get
really excited about it feel free to not
murder people and say that I did it my
fault if how you do it and followers
have turned our dad tonight for me I did
attack him put a few more souls remain
in the hospital that would surely give
some extra credit for the kid extra
credit wow that's amazing the hospital
administrator who stripped down to his
last breath is the judgment of the
underworld this is gonna be a good one
was born in this hospital in the
hospital well-loved the Morgan Lucius
found out that these actually contains
some very useful information that was
the last stop before leaving the
hospital so we need to find it it's any
information about the other son that a
supposedly the devil cool I'm excited
you excited no well you don't have to be
having them I'm playing oh sorry it's
kind of like isn't it emergency x-ray oh
I would good feeling about this one
brace hey Thomas Orton now we can go in
the showers and look at naked people
women ooh damn it damn it are you
serious well I guess man then yes son
oh we can [ __ ] with his shampoo eNOS
I think this game had penis is
impressive good job very well well done
now it's I'm not doing ah
don't show me the peanut
oh you're so annoying we don't even need
to kill you stupid and shower man stupid
stupid stupid stupid chefs you're hungry
[ __ ] a random donut I better eat it yes
eat it that's right [ __ ] you ate it
stupid idiot so to get for being a
stupid idiot stupid idiot alright now we
can open their records yay we found out
something about the story thank you I
was doing havecome they described a very
rare salt allergy they made his blood
boil when he was even in contact with
salt lucious was also diagnosed with
salt allergy early on but the effects
were not nearly this severe she wait
here with your pair he must be more evil
or some [ __ ] hey there's nothing
suspicious about a glowing trolli
there's nothing suspicious you guys a
racist racist hey what are you doing
trying to relieve me back oh you removes
it ah no no no no why do I always game
over every time it's BS it's BS pros
don't worry about it don't worry about
it don't worry about it
it
don't you worry don't you worry don't
you worry don't you worry child Heaven's
got a place for you this is beautiful
and magical and mystical and you are
dead you are green and beautiful I love
you all so very much
you got shrekd you got shrekd you've got
aspect you got a strike you got a strike
get some money get some money that is
could we could we could we
anyway well I tried that's right run
away [ __ ] woo
dynamite nice and watch sorry I gotta go
thanks let's go to the administrator
yeah what just happened
okay while I'm glad we could do that hey
bro how about a shower snack you love
shower snacks don't you he seems a
little [ __ ] perplexed don't worry bro I
got you that's all nice angle nice angle
thank you did he eat it haha so to get
penis man that's what don't don't
don't flash me bro don't none cool they
all die didn't name keep on rocking mate
keep on rocking man this game is so good
he's what G there's the car
you're waited for me that's so nice
thank you I could see it in his eyes
he was worth all right about me seems
that he wasn't the only one trying to
earn a place on his Father's throne
that's a shot suck yard there was
another and he was already a step ahead
and not really the connection had been
severed
no more Knightly visits from Lucifer oh
he's daddy don't love in any mouth
so say no more holding hands tell them
what to do it was a competition and
there could only be one the one who was
able to make all the parties 6:33 gain
the powers needed to sit on the lap of
the one true people if unable all others
would perish with all the rest of the
horse while the apocalypse would sit
upon the living world this was all
preparation for the final conflict
between heaven and earth the final
conflict that would revitalize humanity
and create a new beginning whose
beginning it needs to be see a nice one
nice one
[Music]
Lucius is a pierced Asst he's so pissed
Asst mrs. tomb right now oh my god
he made we made it's all gonna be all
red it's gonna be red
I'm excited to kill some more people yes
I am thank you let's kill oh wow I
wonder Ramabai say God I rhyme la ah
this is so nice
this is so chill it's kind of my life is
strange life is strange isn't it Donna
Miller local lady writer best age I
thinks I can't wait to kill you I can't
wait to kill everyone so don't mind me
I'm just here oh my god thugs the Dark
Lord is awesome
don't worry about it brah gotta flush
the toilet get that power don't worry
about it brah don't worry about it bro I
like what needs to go
I've been started in blood was spilled
on the fields it was then when the
town's emergency horn started its ear
shattering sound this was clearly making
the first horn and it was not Lucius who
had fulfilled this soon the locals would
be here putting the fires out yeah we
can't let that happen
we've got to have a barbecue okay that
was awkward
there's Donna at her best stage again Oh
Donna I love you Donna can't wait to
murder you horribly find a way find a
Bible find a way to get the Bible okay
so the Bible is in here where dear why
do we need a Bible damn it like that's
gonna stop us who has a key okay Kelly
persona I have learned a parakeet that
yes
that's English right there who has the
key know what I got so there's no items
on this [ __ ] map poison thank you
who has the key who has the key he has a
key he wants a coffee no no not a Andrew
we got a lighter that's awesome this
place will burn it will burn that East
volban iPhone albarn a el porn a
prepared a he you will burn it he would
in a war man don't worry babe Wyatt
sorry about that that was a little
awkward I didn't know that was empty I
don't know it's [ __ ] weird [ __ ] oh
god don't touch me don't touch me on
Swedish that's Swedish
don't touch me don't touch me don't
touch me don't touch me don't touch me
don't touch me don't you dare touch me
don't touch me
bra that's right what you gonna do what
you gonna do when you don't have shampoo
[Music]
double kill indeed madman
you're coming should we kill Donna no I
like Donna she's she cool no you're not
done it well then you can die we're
literally killing her for no reason
whatsoever
Oh God for that oh look a fire that's so
nice
Lewis Clark alright it's a barbecue it's
a party it's a party it's a put a party
in the put-upon down here I think that's
how the song goes uh should we kill her
might as well she has a lighter we can
use that lit some more flames baby girl
but I be meta boom but a bang
oh the fire is over ooh
you didn't sound like it quite what's
over yet Oh beautiful magical mystical
and
J says Christ what just happened
damn that's awesome don't even kill
anyone else let's make sure we kill
everyone
where are you going where you going bro
you want to die
wanna die he wants to die he said it he
oh god oh god what is wrong with his
face
I was bandaged thank God oh my god that
scared me
oh god it's almost running out come on
come on come on come on come on
no that's BS oh we need to drink from a
toilet or some [ __ ] to get more power
okay sorry about that that's no we kill
him the [ __ ] just happened
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes spirit that
wasn't beautiful I don't know what
beautiful is laxatives knives can make
people [ __ ] himself why not how do we
get the Bible where must be missing
something bears it must be Pisa the
clear myth seen how about you man
oh my god is gonna be [ __ ] awesome
[Music]
well then would be a shame if there
no don't [ __ ] out don't [ __ ] out don't
[ __ ] out
don't you dare [ __ ] out no you're going
back in there you're going back in there
[ __ ] come on come on little closer oh
my god what it was that what has been
son and cannot be on son man God Oh a
note
kind of clue all alone I want to ride my
bicycle I want to ride my back well that
went splendid let's check out some more
of the shops this is my favorite map so
far it's [ __ ] amazing the bank that
should be good
got no quarter with you Joseph what do
you want I just broke into their [ __ ]
Bank and no one gives a [ __ ]
ooh we can go in there all right I want
to kill her she ate it
stupid [ __ ] ate my pill sandwich maybe
next time you find a sandwich oh god her
throat exploded that's some strong [ __ ]
right there
strong [ __ ] all right now we can go in
the vault
okay what do we get mortise okay
oh cool all right I know where to go now
hi France I never can go in here and get
the Bible Bible done Bible blue
inventory full oh my god more detail it
was time for the seven trumpets upon the
first trumpet sound hail and fire mixed
with blood find a map they said now
listen that was pretty easy except my
inventory is full damn it town it seemed
that the whole stage water treatment
plant is located here this is certainly
not a coincidence there are no
coincidences tonight everything that
happens from now
man that flame looks so real
all right we did it another episode I
had a lot of fun playing brothers if you
enjoyed playing with me not in that way
they'd be like I really appreciate it it
helps me out a lot and I will see you in
the next one
that he was watching and as always stay
awesome
[Music]